foreign
[Music]
welcome everybody to a really Lively
discussion between really dedicated
leaders in the field of HIV and AIDS
that have been at the Forefront really
for decades understanding how to bring
communities and policy makers and
funders together in a new and Innovative
way that results in really listening and
acting at the community level
we all have watched um the last three
years and the impact it's had on our
progress with HIV and we've had a really
great
um alert coming out of unaids to really
tell us
um about where we are and new strategies
coming out of who and new strategies
coming out of pepfar and really an
incredible Global fund replenishment
um and hopefully reauthorization of
pepfar within the next 12 months to
really ensure that there's funding to
really execute but it's really my
pleasure today to have with us four
incredible leaders in the field so Meg
what do you think is critical to the
global HIV response in order for us to
control this pandemic and what do you
think the key Focus needs to be at the
country level and what efforts have to
be redoubled to make sure that we
achieve our goals and not sit back and
say we've done a great job
that's a great question and I'm sure
everybody will have their their views on
this but I what is important in this
time in 2022 is over 2021 and 2022 we
have this sort of synergy of all the
different strategies that are available
so there's no confusion the UNA strategy
the global fund strategy the pepfar
strategy our own Global Health sector
strategies on HIV hepatitis and STI
really have commonalities across and I
and I think all of them speak to number
one person-centered care approaches and
working towards inequalities inequities
and each of the strategies tackle it a
little bit from different lenses such in
you the UNA strategy under which we all
work around inequalities and reducing
those not just the 95 95 95 but the 10
10 10 and reducing stigma and ensuring
that there are no criminal realizations
as well but then there's Precision
prevention coming out from Global fund
sustainable non-stigmatizing care from
from
pepfar and I think from who we have all
of them and we've also take this added
lens of saying there are commonalities
and starting to link that to what are
the commonalities across the three
diseases of HIV hepatitis and STIs and
what are the things that we can do that
will lay a found founding groundwork for
things like primary care because I agree
with you we did really well because
because of the community approaches and
that commitment but I don't I agree with
you as well we haven't strengthened and
bolstered Primary Care to be able to
withstand the next pandemic so for us as
well we've taken at least for this world
AIDS day we want to remember two groups
or a couple of populations we're
focusing our messages around key
populations we have new recommendations
new guidelines lines that are out we
know that the data shows that not
overall seventy percent of all new
infections are happening in key
populations or their partners and then
if you go to some countries that are
starting to see inclines in new cases it
could be up to 90 percent are happening
in key populations in their Partners so
we've somehow forgotten that we have a
big key population
uh challenge because there's so much
stigma and discrimination occurring so
many polarized views we at who says we
need to we need to work with all
populations men who have sex with men
transgender people people who inject
drugs sex workers people who are in
prisons and we also want to work with
Children and adolescents and mother to
child transmission as a way to say we
have a litmus test for elimination if we
can also move and take care of all those
children who've been left behind a
smaller number but if we're able to do
that then I think we'll be able to show
that in all populations we can reach
those who are being left behind in
different programs so from us I think I
always talk about the bookends we want
to use all the new Innovations on the
innovate on the end of reducing new
infections HIV self-testing has been
super important it has moved us to doing
coveted self-testing hepatitis C
self-testing syphilis self-testing is on
the way and I think we need to do more
self-care we want to see prep utilized
whether oral Prep long-acting Prep we
have seen some really exciting data
coming from countries that have
introduced treatment for everyone plus
prep that we're starting to see in
cities zero new infections and key
populations this is Amsterdam this is
London how can we replicate that a
thousand times a hundred thousand times
over and we also want to address the
late stage we don't want to forget
Advanced HIV disease and re-engagement
with care so I think to be able to do
that well you know you need the
continuing of care but Innovations and
also addressing some of those real
structural barriers that have not
allowed us to work with key populations
in all of all of the world because those
are the populations that actually have
to have the services accessible at all
times so I've covered a lot of areas but
let me not dominate the conversation and
pass back to you I'm sure we'll come to
some of the other questions as we move
on thanks
make brilliant points and thank you for
also raising Advanced disease because
you know I've watched the median age of
our HIV cohort go from 30 to 40 and
approaching now 50. what a great what
does that mean to me it means that
people are very motivated to stay on
their treatment and to stay in their
programs that are coming back and are
being seen
um but that comes with another set of
responsibilities as program managers to
really address what you really talked
about is the person-centered care
because person-centered care of a 50
year old is very very different than
person-centered care of a 30 year old
and I really appreciate you talking
about testing as a Gateway because I
think
um viral infectious diseases outside of
HIV and hepatitis have really not been
tested for
um and I think showing that that
self-test work gives us the ability to
really Empower communities to have their
own Gateway
to treatment and prevention by having
their own ability to know their status
as a personal piece particularly when we
get to key populations in the level of
vulnerability and stigma discrimination
and I think that's just raised as such a
critical point
So Reagan unaids has really been at the
Forefront of raising the alert of um
where we are off track I think it's a
perfect time to raise the alert because
we do have six or seven years to really
ensure that we're meaning that I think
the piece put out on danger and danger
was so important what does unaid see as
our key takeaways in getting us back on
track
thank you and it's great to be here with
all of you
um and Meg thank you for those points as
a 55 year old woman living with HIV it's
it's a long journey in life and you know
it's so critical to think about the
whole Arc of it so thank you for that
um it is a moment of Reckoning in the
response we've done we've had many
inflection points and we've made a lot
of progress but we put out that report
in the summer because we are not in a
good place we are not reaching all the
people that you've mentioned Ambassador
and we need to find them and reach them
and it is inequalities it's keeping us
from getting to them and I just want to
paint a little quick picture I know
everyone on this call knows it but the
confounding crises of more than two
years of the war oh sorry more than two
years of uh covid-19 and the war in
Ukraine their combined impact on the
global economy have really undermined
our efforts and we've got energy
political will and funding
understandably diverted from HIV so
we're operating in a much more complex
world and people are not near their
services
which is making it more challenging for
all of us
so while the progress is slowing we're
also seeing an incredibly chilling human
impact and we all know this but every
minute in 2021 a person died of AIDS
every six minute a child died
um it's happening all over the world
Asia Pacific Eastern Europe and Central
Asia Latin America the Middle East North
Africa have all seen seen increases in
new infections and we had 100 1.5
million new infections in 21 which was a
million over our Target for 2020 of no
more than 500 000. so we are really not
in the best place and we know who's most
impacted right the adolescent girls and
young women gay men and men who have sex
with men lgbti people children sex
workers they all face disproportionate
risk so the the barriers are as they
have always been stigma discrimination
criminalization political inaction
insufficient funding and really
inequality and and as you started the
conversation saying it's every type of
inequality that's driving the pandemic
perpetuating it and the pandemic is
exacerbating those inequalities and of
course people have intersecting and
overlapping inequalities and they change
when their circumstances change so it's
a moving Target but a complex one which
is why as you said and Meg pointed out
we have these strategies focused on the
inequalities so while we put out the the
call in the summer saying that we're in
trouble our world AIDS Day Report is
really focused on so what do we do about
it how do we move the needle how do we
advance progress so a couple of the
things that we're looking at doing next
year and some which we've already begun
with co-sponsors including with who and
others we're focused on children so next
year we're going to look at the ways in
which we can most easily find the
children who we've left behind and get
them treated and get them tested early
we're missing kids too too much too
early in their lives and of course that
it's all preventable and all I don't
it's all all avoidable adolescent girls
and young women
um we're also continue to focus on them
and we have a new Global strategic
initiative called Education Plus which
focuses on keeping girls in secondary
school it's a high level political
advocacy effort which Builds on some
work that you've LED and others are
doing in the field on on education for
young women but of course by keeping
them in school we protect them from HIV
and GBP and there's a bi-directional uh
impact for both of those things we all
seem to protect them when they get out
of school but by giving them the life
skills and the empowerment and the
education we hope that we send them off
into the world in a different way and
then gay men and men who have sex with
men
transgender people sex workers are all
facing legal environments which really
keep them from accessing the prevention
and the treatment that's going to save
their lives so we're going to be working
with undp and others next year on
decriminalization we know the landscape
around the world we know where the
policies and laws are bad we'd like to
look at opportunities in places where we
can move move the policies or remove the
laws so that people can feel comfortable
it's hard enough to go to the doctor let
alone if you feel that you're going to
be stigmatized discriminated against or
criminalized or killed these These are
these are the barriers that we're facing
so we know that if we push these
inequalities in a new way and we remove
them it's not an ideological thing it's
it it is a good thing for the world to
do it is the right thing for people to
do but it is also how we solve pandemics
and if we do this for AIDS we'll set
ourselves up better for handling the
pandemics of the future
you know thanks Regan I I think for many
people who aren't in the HIV aids field
they don't realize how important the
unaid's data has been in really giving
us always that Clarity of who we're
missing and then really focusing us on
examples of people who have found the
solutions and I think you know what you
talked about of treatment and prep is
just so extraordinary because showing
that there are cities that are achieving
gives us the hope and the roadmap yes it
has to be adapted yes it's it's
different and it's but I think we're
more alike than we are different and I
think
that we can hold ourselves to that
solution-based approach and but we are
privileged because from the beginning
the granularity of the data has allowed
us to focus on what we need to focus on
and to really move policy and to move
new ideas forward and I think
I just feel privileged to be part of a
of a pandemic that put people and data
at the center so that we could really
understand not only who was showing up
but who couldn't show up and I think
that that is missing in many pandemic
responses and I just think I just thank
you for highlighting the importance of
treatment and prevention because
obviously testing is the gateway to that
and knowing your status and really
making sure that you have access to both
those services and I think that's
something that's often missing in the
covid response no matter what the income
of the country we are not marrying
testing with treatment and prevention so
that people can get the options that
they need that really meet their needs
and it's different as we age where we
live and what we want to really be
focused on and I think programs that are
adaptable to the full range of The Human
Experience is just so important and so
we always point out
and we rightly so of how disappointed we
are in our progress but I think we do
provide a road map of really how to
integrate and put this person-centered
approach that Meg talked about
the slides you're really at that fulcrum
of
um who's missing and this 70 of new
infections in key populations and their
Partners just a really difficult
um issue when you look at the legal
framework and the community Frameworks
in many of these countries
what Solutions do we need to really
close that gap for access to testing and
treatment where people feel safe
um feel safe accessing testing feel safe
accessing Prevention Services and feel
safe accessing treatment
thanks for the question and thanks for
inviting itpc thanks for inviting me I
think as you point out the outlook for
key populations is embarrassingly
disproportionate right we have even more
recent data from our community-led
monitoring in Malawi that compared
access to testing services before covid
and then during covid and we saw that
the largest gap was among female sex
workers and the testing fell by almost
80 percent key populations as they are
known I think we need to remind
ourselves their key pops we kind of just
call them that but remember that they
are the most affected populations most
affected people groups and you know I I
have sat on this question for quite some
time and really you know what makes them
more effective than others I would argue
at the core of it it's because HIV is a
moralized disease and uh the gaps that
we persistently see with specific groups
of people are less due to Medical
clinical scientific and molecular issues
and more of Human Rights and political
issues and I think to close these gaps
we need to work on the political levers
to alleviate stigma and access my strong
belief is that we too often comfortably
sit inside of our our little Echo
Chambers and listen to our results of
our research and what we could do to
make some sort of incremental change on
you know but is that enough and don't
get me wrong I don't think that
um I'm not saying that research is not
important but we do we really need that
much more evidence to address these
access gaps and maybe if I could put it
a different way do we think that in
countries with punitive laws and
policies that more evidence would
actually change the minds of lead Rose
and that's what I'm saying I think we
need to start thinking much more outside
of the clinical and the HIV or even the
health space and much more playing the
party in the political space I would
argue that we would need more more
robust Level Society that it can
actually ensure that we have leaders who
can see all people as humans with equal
rights to access to Quality Health and
leaders that deliberately design
incentives in the system to ensure that
that happens we know that for key
populations that care LED and care
provided services are the most effective
for engagement and for retention and for
testing right in an Ideal World there
would be more support and investment for
community and parallel Services which
would directly address stigma quality of
services provided and in turn start to
close these gaps and I want to make one
second Point here that we also have I
think we have a data problem all up in
Euro alley Ambassador Brooks let me see
if I tread carefully here but I think
it's just too easy for countries and
we've said this before for countries to
claim achieving HIV targets by masking
the inequities in their sub-populations
and you know was looking at some U.N
AIDS data for 2022 Epi estimates it was
just in February 2022 looking at the
progress towards the 95s in Zimbabwe way
and they paint a very pretty picture for
almost full achievement already if you
look at the adults the adult populations
but once you start disaggregating and
looking at gay men other men who have
sex with men and transgender communities
you see it totally different and unequal
picture and as you said this is the kind
of granularity that we need to get the
interventions in the right place the
Nuance that comes from understanding why
barriers exist not just what virus exist
and why people for example don't return
to health clinics or the data that shows
that the time to get your viral load
test to be used with a doctor is what
counts for actual people on the ground
rather than the time it takes to get
back to the clinic and our data shows
that user fees are still imposed through
uh services that were feet free and we
need to get more demand side data for
more calibrated interventions I think
you said this before but I think
sometimes we feel like we have the
correct data but we may be asking the
correct question or asking the same
question but you need a different answer
from a different perspective and so you
may have the same indicator but you need
the recipient of care the demand side
perspective and if you come with an
attitude of well we know that already
well then we're actually not going to
learn anything new I think this is more
important and now given our global
economic recession uh whereas supposedly
rich countries are even having austerity
measures and small National Health
budgets are even smaller we have put the
little money that goes into Health needs
to go into the right place and I would
say that targeted Community Investments
are the future
foreign
that was terrific and powerful and I
think what has really what I really
learned over the last decade
um was the investment that the global
fund made in community-led monitoring
was incredibly powerful
because it brought together both
quantitative and qualitative data that
gave us a lens that we couldn't see
before and I think it totally changed
how pepfar invested in community-led
monitoring and I think and that wouldn't
have happened if someone hadn't started
that investment and you could really see
it and I think this launch this is what
you're really bringing up that these new
things have to be funded but funded from
the community lens and I I've always
been struck by if you look at rate of
new infections prior to the war in
Ukraine versus Russia was a perfect
example of how peer-led Services Trump
country LED our host government-led
Services
by you know a miraculous amount because
the Ukraine's new infections were going
down and the Russian's new infections
were going up and and the difference was
um not the amount of money invested but
how that money was invested and I think
you're you're talking about these smart
Investments
um in health because money is limited
it's just so important but then ensuring
that we have community-led monitoring so
we can interpret the data appropriately
and I think that's such a critical point
Michael though the work on ensuring
people have access I mean you rage this
Solange
access to their viral load data because
that is actually the critical empowering
piece for decision making at the
personal level and I think U equals
youth campaign and prevention access and
certainly you have let been a strong
voice in peer empowerment to understand
testing both diagnostic testing but also
monitoring within HIV so
you've really been at the community
level can you give us some examples of
how U equals U has really empowered the
community and the individuals and how
that can be taken to scale and will the
recent who guidance on a particular
viral load level really help us Advance
better monitoring in countries to really
Define that U equals u in a more clear
and impactful way Michael
sure thank you Ambassador so good to see
you and so good to see you all and I
think again there's no better person
that can speak about data more than you
can so thank you for all you've been
doing and you've done around this work
for a long time I think obviously uh
yukuz is a clear and effective simple
way to convey the fact that personally
with HIV who is an antideratory therapy
and whose virus is the Press cannot
transmit HIV to social Partners it is
that simple but as we know it has not
been that simple to implement and the
data and the science has proven that it
is that simple but I think the world and
the field are struggled in implementing
I think you spoke about it earlier on
about why you know we create policies
but actually those policy living shells
and pack our goal as well as being to
make sure we Empower our community
members so that they feel empowered to
take this message to the adopters to the
Healthcare centers and tell them I want
to know my viral load number I want to
know if I'm very suppressed tell me if I
value because that's a huge motivation
to stay on treatment and that's why it's
so critical and we are so great for who
for this guideline because it's going to
help the field understand what does it
mean to be value suppressed and how what
is it what does nobody need to be and
how can you help you transform the way
you see yourself as a pill HIV person so
I think again just going back briefly
and why the U equals you search a
transformative message right because
obviously it improves the quality of
life for people living HIV and reduces
stigma I think that stigma part is so
critical as someone living literally
myself and as a gay man and having to
deal with double stigma for living with
HIV but also as a gay person so I have
to deal with those stigma issues but
having the fact that you can tell your
partner that you cannot transmit HIV
sexually that you can actually have kids
that have a message is so transformative
for everyone everywhere and it's so
important that we give the information
to people so they can use that message
for their health care for themselves
ourselves but also it's not just for
themselves it's actually for the field
because we know that if people are
undetectable each value is a press they
cannot transmit HIV and what does that
mean it means we can reduce new
infections so it's not just a personal
benefit it actually leads to the world
any epidemic I think that's what we've
not actually collapsed so at Park what
we've been doing the last couple of
years is yes we want to share the
message of you equals you to individuals
but actually it's more than that we know
if we can get community members very
suppressed
new HIV infections are not coming from
the sky they are coming from somewhere
so if people who are living with HIV
have the equality of Life are very
suppressed they cannot transmit HIV
they got such a critical point and I
think what's always struck me about HIV
and the work there is the community is
always ahead of the Physicians and
nurses and policy makers and I think
um I know it must be incredibly
frustrating to people in the community
or like we've been pushing this ball up
that's a huge sub for all this time
but I think you know part of it is
not measuring the right things at the
programmatic level and you know what is
the right thing well it's as you
described the right thing is does that
client know it's by those his or her
viral load and do they know what that
means for their life
um and I think that Gap is still not
being addressed at the program level and
we have to treat every that it's a
programmatic failure if the client
doesn't have those two pieces of
information both their viral load and
the impact that that viral load has on
their life and I think that you just
that is such a critical piece and I'm
hoping so let me pose the next question
and we're gonna go in reverse order so
Michael you're going to be like up again
so when you look about the last three
years and what the health systems have
gone through and and unaids report and
who oh acknowledgment of this issue of
70 percent of the new infections
in a health system that often didn't
serve that 70 of the new infections
what did you see over the last three
years that gave you hope
um in in covet and HIV twin pandemics
and things that work that you didn't
think would work and then what really
gives you pause about the one thing that
you think was severely impacted in the
HIV response that as unaids has really
alerted that we need to get back on
track so Michael from your standpoint on
the ground what do you what surprised
you as good and what surprised you as
really bad that needs to be immediately
addressed
thank you and one one thing I would just
add is I think there will be no covered
response if it wasn't for PL HIV and key
populations and CS organizations on the
ground I think that's that's that's just
been so clear if those infrastructures
wasn't in place in places across the
world there will be no covered response
and that's that's but I think in doing
that you know we've lost a lot of
investment in the community because
they've had to like you know stretch
themselves to respond to their
communities and to immediately adapt the
way they respond so that they can sort
of Provide support for covert response
and they've lost a lot of Staff members
there's a lot of funding and a lot of
structures in place due to their
response to covet so I think that's one
critical aspect because in the last
three years we've seen a lot of
community of based organizations either
that a lot of Staff members to covet or
that lost funding that is no more in
place are strongly now to sort of
continue to provide services that it
normally provided before their offices
are not the same anymore and sort of
again one what that has led to we've
seen reduction in people who have
enrolled in HIV uh medication like who
are the only treatment and they're not
coming back to continue treatment
and it's it's and they've they've been
lost to care quote unquote so this
report there have been lost to follow up
but can't find them anymore because
again we've lost staff members we the
fund is not it's not it's not the same
anymore and now due to covet people the
organizations that were in place in
these communities are no longer as
funded or have the same capacity to
break people they reached before
Michael such a critical how do you raise
two I I just I think incredibly key
points in it one is and I've been trying
to say this but I think people just roll
their eyes and say okay yeah I like you
know there wouldn't have been any
ability to diagnose covid if there
hadn't been HIV none of those machines
would have been there without HIV and
HIV TB none of them and none of the
laboratory Personnel none of the
community groups that were critical in
Outreach um and and knowledge transfer
which was so critical I think the other
piece that you raise is you're
absolutely right when people get
stressed and they're trying to serve
clients the first thing to go is data
and data transcription
um we see that all over the world and I
think that is such an essential point
and the third point that you make and I
I'm hoping
I'm hoping that we really make this at
all levels and that we have HIV people
sitting around the table in these
pandemic preparedness plans because what
I keep saying in the United States is
stop planning for a pandemic we have one
let's address that one and if we put
those structures in place to address
that one successfully we'll have the
structures that we need to address the
new one I mean it's just this theoretic
pandemic preparedness has never worked I
mean the United States states spent 20
years planning for a pandemic
and none of those plans worked because
it it didn't depend on testing as we all
know in HIV is a gateway so you know
these I always keep saying if you can
respond to HIV TB and malaria and the
current covid-19 pandemic successfully
and you treat every new infection and
you treat every hospitalization and you
treat every death as a failure of
programming and you fix it then you'll
be ready for the next pandemic rather
than spending money on theoretic
preparedness rather than actual
Community engagement that supports a
system so Michael thank you for raising
those issues because I think it's really
the Crux of what I hope comes out of
world AIDS day because the HIV groups
bore the brunt of the covid response yet
haven't been reimbursed and further
supported for the incredible work that
they did so launch how do you look at
this from your perspective of knowing
Asia and Africa so well
yeah I think uh Michael said quite a lot
of what I was going to say which I I'm
happy that he raised the same points I I
don't think I was I mean in a pleasant
way I wasn't really surprised but I was
reassured that you know the future is
community-led right the hiv-derived
health infrastructure and the community
architecture was at the front line of
the covert response globally I don't
think anywhere
I could say that that was not the case
we saw pair workers Community
Innovations like for hand washing very
concrete things
and we had you know normative agencies
asking organizations like itbc and our
partners you know what was going on what
are you seeing what are you hearing
really being The Heirs on the um The
Heirs and the eyes on the ground and
Community was able to rise to that
challenge I also was very happy to see
like oh yeah multi-month dispensing
which we had been begging for forever or
maybe you can do that now maybe you can
put more than a month in in someone's
hand and I saw that really increase so
lots of more of self-testing at home
methadone programs
the you know really highlighting again
the importance of treatment education
and health education as those things
were rolled out but really just going
back to that point about autonomy like
people if they get the correct kind of
information can actually take care of
their health and it doesn't have to this
supervisory role of the doctor and the
clinician and seeing me every five
minutes is is really not necessary so I
think we started to see a trend and a
move in that direction so the community
rising up and the community data
Community insights really being able to
help with the covid response and HIV but
on the flip side everything was covered
covet I mean literally that's one of the
quotes from from one of our qualitative
interviews the lady said well what do I
have to say it's just covered coven when
we asked her what was happening with HIV
I think we have some of those unintended
consequences we talked already about the
machines being co-opted from you know
that should have been used for viral
load not being used for covet testing
and you know they're also under intended
consequences such as like you know the
social distancing and meaning to line up
outside very practical things when you
haven't disclosed your your status and
you're like oh I see so-and-so on the
street and therefore they are lining up
and so you have confidentiality issues
and then you want to know why people are
not coming back and we know that many of
our new initiations are not you know
treatment naive they're actually people
who were lost in the system and just not
coming back and so I think that was you
know really important to to note you
know the the issue in Kenya still
bothers me I mean they're still having
issues with commodities and the the idea
Michael's here talking about U equals U
is theory if you really can't get a
viral load test and you can't get your
results
prep is a theory if you can't do a basic
HIV test and these things were expired
and we're still having Commodities
issues
and so I think it's time to now regain
what we've lost and we need to realize
that we're dealing with two things and
you have to deal with both I think to my
mind you know when high income countries
um became under threat it was very
difficult for middle and low income
countries to get PPE to get tests to get
I mean the whole piece of the global
supply chain fell apart based on ability
to pay
so getting the struggle that I had to
get PPE gloves into Africa I mean it was
just phenomenal in the end I did
something I wasn't supposed to do but
that's my job
um and I just said you know we're not
gonna buy American we're just gonna find
it anywhere and we're gonna get got it
to sub-Saharan Africa because we can't
have everybody at risk but I think to me
that opened up a giant chasm
um where we have focused a lot on human
resources for health and we kind of just
said oh the supply chain
um but I think the supply chain failed
us it failed us globally but it failed
us particularly in medium and low-income
countries
um and particularly vulnerable
populations because there may have been
well-off individuals who could get an
HIV test or a covet test or viral load
monitoring but not
um the average Community member and I
think
um I think that you're absolutely right
the fragility of our response in that
Global context
became really evident in who was left
behind
um and it was clear and I think you I
really thank you for raising that
because I I do believe there's a
fragility in who was left behind and I I
think I worry all the time that these
coveted plans aren't going to result I
mean these pandemic response plans are
not going to have tangible indicators to
me tangible indicators are does every
Community member get on HIV test that
wants one did they know the results do
they have access to prevention and
treatment services and do they have
access to viral load monitoring and does
it get to them I mean these are kind of
like fundamental simple pieces but if it
isn't working in HIV it's not going to
work in covet and I think what covet has
shown us is that all respiratory
diseases look alike so if you want to
know what's new you've got to diagnose
what's there which means that you really
have to have access to communities and
clients and I think that at peace that
moving from a theoretic plan to an
actual on the ground implementation is
still
too vague I think in all of these
response plans and I think what you
bring to the table is clarity
you know you don't need to have covet
data just let's see how we failed in
getting viral load back to the clients I
mean that's a or getting three months
meds I mean this is really we have
SIMPLE indicators and I think finally
with your community-led monitoring data
I think too many people focus on an
absolute number
when what is really important is the
trend lines
you know are we bringing back more
individuals that were lost what are
their age groups who are we still
missing those trend lines really tell us
our programs working or not
data can always be missing you know it's
it's so imperfect so I'm not sure an 85
is different than 105.
but I know if I've gone from 85 to 105
it's vastly different than going from
105 to 85. and I think those kinds of
Pieces Just are not understood when
people want to just focus on a number
rather than the directionality of that
number
so Regan
how are we going to measure this how are
we going to make sure that we're making
progress have you developed new
indicators that communities can measure
so that we can really look at the
programs and if they're having the
impact that we need them to have
well thanks and actually Solange made so
many great points um some of us going to
make about the importance of this
community-led monitoring work which is
still we need to refine it and and
develop ways to get it relayed to the
policy makers and and to help us shape
the the programmatic stuff in a
different way
um I think so the answer is we need to
connect those dots more than we do and I
think just to emphasize three things
about that one that real-time real-life
intelligence from the ground has always
been and you said it it's like we know
on the ground where the problems are and
what the solutions are far faster than
we can ever make policies to fix them
and we need to make that you know
instantaneous
um relay of intelligence to to people
who are who are doing the work and we
saw it happen in Ukraine right we saw
you know the peer-led systems and the
multi-month multi-month dispensing work
so well proving that we don't
necessarily always need a formal health
system and that peer-to-peer stuff does
often work better and and the point that
you made Solange too about trusting
people and which goes back to the very
early conversations around HIV can
Africans tell time can they do at right
intervals you know it's it's sort of
insulting as a person living with HIV
that we think we need this heavy
um you know sort of supervision and and
I've often thought that maybe people who
are newly exposed to HIV or newly um
connected to care might need extra time
and attention but certainly someone like
myself who's been living with a disease
for two and a half decades can use fewer
resources and can actually be part of
the solution right how can I and people
like me um like Michael's doing and
others
help people understand what we're living
with and also make make the case as
advocates because I think coming back to
this intersection of data and policy and
the whole conversation we're having
you're right it doesn't it doesn't make
any difference unless we can Implement
these things and quickly right and I
think if when I look at covid in some of
the areas where things went well for HIV
it was shocking and in a good way how we
could keep the systems together and how
um we could learn and adapt and and and
save lives even in the most threatening
and difficult of circumstances so we can
we just proved we can do it now how do
we do that at scale and it's taking data
like you have Solange and making sure
that we also look at the data
um in the unaids report and and
disaggregate it and tell the true story
so that it's not we're not masking real
problems because we're looking at
numbers that are aggregated or general
and I think we've done that increasingly
we've looked at more granular data we
have looked at identifying who's really
at risk but it's these real life things
I remember I was a long time ago but I
was um in Africa talking to women about
the female condom and asking them why
they weren't using it or what they felt
about it and this woman came up to me
and she said she had a shovel and she
said come with me and we went outside
and she said try to dig a hole and the
ground was like cement and she's like
where am I gonna put this thing she's
like I think it's a good thing I might
use it but I can't get rid of it and I
was like oh my gosh you know an aspect
of it that I had never even considered
um so I think really understanding the
real world implementation of this and
then just I wanted to come back to the
two points Michael made one was on um
on the value of the virola test and
knowing your status you know having that
uh goal of of knowing that you're not
infectious and what that does to your
own self-stigmatization I remember
feeling wildly different about myself
when I knew that I could not infect
anybody I would never have infected
anybody but just knowing that
biologically I could move through my
home where I lived with my family or
hold my sister's baby or and give my
sister's child a bath or you know double
dip my French fries in someone's ketchup
without ever thinking about it changed
my life and I think when I'm talking to
people who are um thinking about being
in my life or just trying to help people
be comfortable with HIV I say you know
we're some of the safest people to be
around we know what we have we're
treated for it and we're tested all the
time for everything else and gosh we
probably don't want to get anything else
so I think it's a powerful message both
to the world but also it helps people
living with HIV recover some of that
personal dignity and strip away the
self-stigmatization that happens as well
um and that of course then leads to
lower rates of infection and I
appreciate your point there and then
lastly on the financing I agree you know
we are we've gone around in circles on
this for a long time and unaids is about
to lead a conversation with some
Partners in Washington to think about
financing Beyond Oda and to look at the
bigger spaces
um you know what are we doing with the
reallocation of special drawing rights
at the World Bank what are we doing with
um debt reduction what are you know
we've talked about these in theory over
the years but now how do we actually
move the needle so that we can get some
of those
um releases in the in the economic
system because we can't just go hunting
in a fresh hunting ground and then
battle other people for the same money
we have to figure out how we can make
all of the money work and finally I just
think you know and Buster your point
about
investing in these systems that we
already have and perfecting them so that
we can we we don't need to reinvent the
wheel it's so simple and so obvious but
I don't think enough people understand
what we have built through HIV and the
value of it globally and how we should
just continue to invest it so final
Point find the money and put it put it
on the on the community level and and
solve the problems when you know when
people say well we can't fund small ngos
or we can't fund small community-led
work you know projects on the ground
because because because figure it out in
the system you know find a way to get
the money to them and help them if they
can't do the reporting or the or there
are issues with with running the money
through them and I think that's
something that we can all work to change
Regan thank you for raising that I I'm
I'm stunned how we always create our own
roadblocks by building on our own
perceptions and assumptions about things
I mean we self stop doing things because
we say oh this will never work or we
can't do that or that's
um I I remember when um people said to
me no hospital will report the new
admissions they're too busy and you know
I'm like did you ask them
so I went and I asked the 6000 hospitals
I said would you report new admissions
for covid because I need to really get
you what you need and I can't based on
you know who's been in the hospital for
100 days I need to know who's newly
admitted I had 93 reporting that first
week so I think we we sometimes hold
ourselves back by saying no one will do
this and I think our real challenge is
every time we hear that and I think who
and unaids are so critical to this is
every time we hear that from a
programmer or a donor is we need to say
did you try
what have you done to try so Meg please
well there's been so much territory
covered here and I'm not even sure I can
recall the first question but I wanted
to build on a couple of things that were
were said about the the covid
um what surprised me with the covid
um pandemic and then what's happened
since and I think building on that I was
very surprised that it took us a while
at
um at the global level to understand
what resources were available around the
world and that I think is a failing of
communication across across departments
across teams across ministries of Health
Etc that it did take a while for people
to know how much was there in terms of
viral load capacity in countries and
that this could be utilized in lower
middle income countries I was really
surprised and still remained surprised
now with the the monkey pox
um uh outbreak that it takes a long time
to move things to low and middle income
countries and that we're not thinking
about this from the get-go and that this
isn't worked into our plans from the
start and with monkeypox it was but it's
just taken us a longer time than I would
have expected for us to make sure that
there's access to testing treatments and
vaccines
I was surprised as well about both the
positive and the negatives of what is
happening
um on the internet
you know so there was so much
communication we were inundated with
communication excellent indicate
communication this supported what we
were doing in terms of all the mentions
of the differentiated models of care the
self-testing the self-care the virtual
visits for HIV also about the
information about
um covid what to do where to get them
but then at the same level it has
created uh I guess a global community
that believes they know
what's good and what's bad and that
there's a constant need to bring forward
um evidence and messages around science
and I think that's been surprising to
organizations like who and others where
um now every time our messages also has
to be how do we make sure science is
really well understood and that
everybody can understand what we're
saying
um because the infidemic was really I
think very surprising and
it has led to us still having problems I
would say in having the world fully
vaccinated for Call of it we still in uh
in Africa we would like to see 70 of all
African nations being able to vaccinate
um for covid but we don't we're not
there yet and I would say that that is
something that we would want everyone
with HIV to have the opportunity to have
access to a vaccine
um and so I think also from the global
Health architecture around pandemic
preparedness as you're mentioning and
alluding to investor
we have to work into that architecture
the Essential Health Services and
maintenance a thing that all the work
that we've done around HIV around TV
around ncds and I think sometimes the
loudest voice gets the biggest seat at
the table for those actions and and we
need to have all of those Essential
Health Services well articulated in any
pandemic preparedness and it's not just
to say there is a base of data
collection supply chain Etc that can be
used but that we have to maintain these
services and we can't forget about them
and we can't allow more deaths to happen
because of the essentials visits missed
than actual say covid pandemic debts I
mean and that's what happened we had
many more Global deaths related to the
fact that people didn't get to their HIV
services or their cancer services or
their screening then actually to covet
and so we have to somehow be able to do
both of these and do both of them well
and I think that's going to have to be
worked into all of these pandemic tools
and ensuring that Community as well is
maintained at the table as these are
negotiated
and that would be one thing that I think
is also difficult probably for Community
we've talked a lot about how
community-led Services there's so much
to be learned there but that's also
being strep you're being stretched
because you're coming to the table for
monkey pox you're coming to the table
for covid you're trying to keep the
voice going on all on TV as well as HIV
and that's difficult to do and I think
it stretches people as they they look
forward it's like where do you put your
energy and how do we make sure that
those messages are will I guess
reflected back from all public health um
Public Health groups ministries of
Health Etc so that it's not just
dependent on somebody always coming and
saying look you've forgotten this or
bring us to the table so there were so
many excellent things discussed I would
have to say
we're not we haven't figured it out and
I think we're going to have to make sure
that uh we're at the table for all of
these pandemic discussions and
community-based Community programs so
important but it can get lost if we're
not there and we're not having that
discussion and just see what happened
with monkey pox we were able to respond
to Monkey pox because of communities
right that's what's happened they're the
ones leading the research they're the
ones leading the communication
everything and I think our traditional
response is there but it's slowly moving
through its paces and that's something
that we won't have time for and that's
where we have to say Okay we we've shown
that we haven't learned all the lessons
we need to for the next pandemic when it
comes
um so I'll stop there thanks
Meg I think he raised such an important
point that both Solange Regan and
Michael also raised is
your ability to show that you are
empowering communities to know their
status to have access to testing that
they have access then to both prevention
and treatment services and then they
have access to the monitoring that they
need that's independent of the
Infectious agent and I think what we
ought to go back and look at is
in each of those areas in the coved
response where did we fail because I
think it's where we failed early on in
HIV and we would be working together to
fix those things but you know the
problem was not and the problem today is
not
um vaccines in country the problem is
vaccine and arms the problem is not
pacs-loved in a pharmacy the problem is
covet testing and access to paxilovit at
the community and I think if we and
because I think this is one place where
the high income middle income low income
countries all share the same issues is
that disconnect between having a tool
and having a tool that's actually
available and utilizable at the
community level and I am still shocked
that the number of people who just say
it's there and I'm like what do you mean
it's there I mean it's not there people
don't know it's there and they don't
know how to use it so I think what I'm
hoping that
on global fund or Global fund pepfar
kind of can go back and look at the
covid response in the region and say you
know the objectively this is where we
had problems and this is how the
community has always responded to this
and has an HIV and can bring that talent
because I think people don't understand
that the solutions are already there so
let's move to key populations in our
final minutes because I think all of you
have said that that's our biggest Gap
it was our biggest Gap 40 years ago it's
our biggest Gap still so we have not
really been able to comprehensively
um bring prevention testing treatment
and monitoring to the group's most
vulnerable most marginalized and most in
need
um I know Meg you talked about cities
and what we can learn from London that
are now at zero infections
how can that information be translated
to low and low income and middle income
resource limited settings how can we
take those Lessons Learned and make it
available immediately not the decade it
took us to bring treatment to Africa but
that knowledge base what is it going to
take
um what can and I'm going to ask each of
you what kind of
who do what can unaids do and what can
the community do to really ensure that
we're holding ourselves accountable to
that translation and really mapping
whether we're making progress day after
day
um because it's a little a little bit
disconcerting that we're really almost
in the same place
um in not reaching the groups that we
know we need to reach so Meg I'm going
to start with you this time
all right well thanks and I think you
know we're taking we're working on this
very seriously and I and I do believe
that the examples that are coming out of
London and some other cities can easily
be transferable meaning that it's it's
taking the concept that uh Michael was
alluding to that people who are on
treatment know that their treatment will
it went virally suppressed means they
are not going to be transmitting and
that's going to reduce the number of new
infections secondly making sure that we
have available prep I think in many ways
people are waiting for the new shiny
innovation of long-acting injectable
prep which is great and we know it's
going to work well when it's available
it's not yet available but or these kind
these cities that have reduced new
infections have been using oral prep in
combination with treatment so as well as
regular testing and self-testing so that
people are aware and are coming into
Services Services have to be much more
accessible and I think one of the things
we have been talking about is reducing
stigma and discrimination and I do think
that we we're there are a lot of tools
there are a lot of programs there are a
lot of approaches to reducing stigma and
discrimination whether it's self-stigma
but also stigma within the health care
setting and in facilities we have to
actually in this is something that who
is trying to take on and needs the help
we've spent 20 30 years looking at
reducing a stigma and discrimination yet
it still is an issue in many places so
what is it that we can do is it a
training is it ongoing quality of care
monitoring it is is it changing health
care workers in different settings is it
you know the community the monitoring
where there's an immediate report so
that the the the activities in a in a
setting of a healthcare setting is
reported back that this is not high
quality care or there are issues and I
and I think that will help us to to
bring these models to other settings
and then again I think we have to look
at those countries who are saying
they're at 95 95.95 the the countries
that have really
indicated that they're there we've seen
that with Botswana for example it can be
incredibly motivating and a positive
political message to say that they're on
the path to elimination for mother to
child transmission of HIV and syphilis
and now we're having hepatitis B there
but to be honest that could be a way to
get certain countries certain con cities
to say we want zero to infections or we
believe we can get on the path to
elimination and that can become a big
political feedback loop to say now you
you're making progress keep on that path
and we've seen it for uh hepatitis for
example there we don't know how many
countries want us to certify them for
eliminating hepatitis C that's a program
where we have a cure
I think we need to do the same for HIV
and it may be by districts it may be by
cities it may be by populations but that
is what I believe we're going to need to
do over and over again to reach our um
to actually reach our 2030 targets and
um so with I think with key populations
we just need to ensure also all of us
that we're doing our best to reduce any
kind of
um challenges or difficulty in language
and we we've seen that we've seen that
there has been a real
um uh how do we say a a very polarized
set of countries right now and what
we've learned in those polarized
countries is that we need to be able to
communicate in a way so that people
still get the services that they need
um and we need to be able to ensure that
those services are happening and and
that's something that who is taking on
in all all of our regions so it's not
just in Africa but it's across we have
to do the same level of work in our
Eastern Mediterranean Southeast Asian
countries in our Eastern European
countries
um and and and find Champions where we
can who want to drive that agenda
um so that everyone has equal access and
uh and that uh we're talking about
stigma discrimination in real ways so
that there are changes there
so from our point of view
um
we want to to see this happening in the
next
five years eight years and so every two
years I think we're gonna have to come
back and say are we doing well on this
where are the countries who are really
shining what can we do to
um ensure that they have recognition for
the make the amount of work and the
amount of success that they've had in
getting to zero in certain areas or in
certain populations
thank you Meg I think sometimes
um we talk about all the good but
sometimes we have to just admit we
failed
um and and and
I think sometimes I saying you know how
do we you know work with Health Service
delivery when it's clear that they're
not going to change is to say
okay we need a different model
um for individuals and I think being
very clear about
um now that we're very clear about the
risk of new infections being very clear
that whatever we're doing is failing
um and we're getting further behind and
so the systems we have put in place the
way we've delivered testing the way
we've delivered prevention the way we've
delivered treatment the way we've
delivered viral lobe monitoring for
certain populations has failed Regan
well great I think um you know at unaids
we've recently reconfigured ourselves to
have a to form a new Branch focused on
policy advocacy and knowledge and and
the main focus there is to do as we've
been talking about get these policies
off the shelf and mobilize politically
so that we can change the things that
are keeping us from making progress so I
think thinking very clearly with our
partners on the ground and our
co-sponsors and others about what can we
now do we understand the problem really
well and and it's been said in various
moments in this discussion we're really
good at identifying the problem maybe we
need to refine the data a little bit but
but now how do we get on with it so you
know the the framing of our world AIDS
day messaging this year is equalized but
what does that mean if you're a
political leader and I think we have a
lot of Education that we need to do we
have new political leaders in many
countries around the world including in
um the US which is one of the largest
donors to the global AIDS response many
of the people who started pepfar and
Global fund have retired and moved on
and I think we have a light bench of of
people coming up through the ranks who
understand this work well and I think we
need to do some of the things that we
did at the beginning which is both
putting people on the ground
um with people whose lives hang in the
balance of their political decisions and
helping them understand that you know
these laws these policies these funny
decisions are made by human beings by
people by groups of people who have
their own agendas politically and their
own agendas collectively politically but
we did a great job influencing them with
HIV in in the early stages and I think
we need to bring back some of the
original
um Playbook moves um because again we
have fresh people we we who work in the
field tend to think this is all well
understood but but again we have new
partners
um I think you know also helping
everybody understand that these gender
inequalities and harmful gender Norms
are really bad for any epidemic not just
aids for any epidemic
um and the gender-based violence
increases women's vulnerable
vulnerability to HIV but we saw you know
in covid um incidents of gbv go up and
we saw
um people who were transgender and gay
or men who have sex with men being
criminalized and targeted in lockdowns
in covid so we really need to reinforce
the human rights work that we're doing
and make sure that everybody is well
protected and that the environments are
enabling and safe for people to just
save their own lives you know I think
it's it's one of those things that is so
it's so obvious
um you know we also talk about the need
to change toxic uh masculinity which
drives a lot of different things
including men's own willingness to uh
access the health care or take care of
their Partners or disclose information
so I think there's an educational Arc
here that needs to continue
um but also be be redoubled and it's you
know listening to both um Buster and you
Meg it's always that hard balance
between wanting to reward the positive
and say that we can do this and also be
honest about where we're failing and
really prod those people and that's the
hardest part in some ways for me about
messaging around this particular disease
is that we have made un Unthinkable
progress and they're you know countries
and communities and groups of people
doing things that no one could ever
imagine and having success that's
incredible
um and then countries that completely
ignore their pandemic or epidemic or lie
about the data so we can't we can't end
the pandemic until we access everybody
and we we know this to be true it's
biologically a fact and so how do we how
do we move
um and for me I think it's unaids it's a
lot of we have a lot of renewed focus on
political advocacy and influencing and
changing finally changing the culture in
which the politicians and and decision
makers live and a lot of that comes back
to some of the things you were saying
Solange and Michael about getting those
perspectives of the people who we're
serving and who are living through this
connecting them to
um the decision makers um not just
having to see the table but really
giving them the ability to negotiate
with them and as you are all saying
shape the future of the thinking on
pandemics
if you want to learn how to stop a
pandemic go to the people who've been
doing it for 40 years
thank you Reagan I think that that last
sentence is is somehow when you take the
policy makers and the decision makers
into the field
they have to understand that last
sentence
um because I think that's just that's
sustainable funding that we need for the
HIV Community has to come out of that
preparedness fund because you can't be
theoretically prepared you need to be
actually prepared and that means you
actually have to be providing Services
um so this to me has never been
theoretic um I know it's never been
theoretic to any of you all but to many
people it is theoretic it's words on
paper rather than actions on the ground
and I think really helping people
understand that is so crucial to
launched
um
you know like there's the no do Gap
we know what to do but we don't do it
you can take that at the global leader
level at the national level and you can
do that the clinical level and I I try
to understand why does that Gap persist
and a comeback specifically an HIV
um that shines a light on it it's a
moralized issue somehow this disease is
not like you know your regular oil
hypertension sort of situation like
there's something here that says we're
just not going to deal with those groups
of people and I come back to the fact
that we need to speak truth to ourselves
and we need to get more politically
Savvy and start to step outside of the
regular participants in our discussion
and start thinking how we can pull the
political levers and I I do think that
with kovid there was there was a you
know global scale example of what
misinformation could look like and how
how even information at a local level
if not messaged accurately for
communities makes no sense so when you
say if you have comorbidities I'm sorry
what does that mean to the regular man
on the street even I am like okay which
of the comorbidities and or what is what
is the comorbidity and you then you have
literal language uh translation that
that has to go through and then you can
understand why people are confused and
why there was an uptake of certain
Therapeutics or vaccines or whatever it
is if you're thinking about monkeypox or
uh you know HIV prep anything putting it
out there as you say is not any reason
for why uh people will get it look I I
think about
um the the the last uh treatment access
survey that itbc did and we you know I
was expecting lots of things about viral
load and you know you kind of anticipate
what the survey is going to tell you but
the most pervasive issue was stigma and
so there's no way that we could ignore
that and I think that we have to
remember that community-led monitoring
or Community interventions but I am
focusing on monitoring today because I
think it is really important
um is is is a model that can be applied
and to anything it could be for voter
fraud it's for what communities see as a
problem and they develop the indicators
for those pain points and track that
over time and so I think it's really
important to know that community-led
monitoring not only shines a light on an
issue but it can also bring solutions to
the table we know what to do because of
the lived experiences as communities
being able to say what the solutions are
so when you apply that in the stigma
context and you think about key
populations we know that you get a
certain Nuance as who asks the question
number one is is gives you a different
response when I ask my kids am I the
best mother they say yes and when you
when I ask when they ask their peers and
like maybe there's a different answer
comes through so I think we really need
to to interrogate whether or not we are
applying community-led monitoring to the
places where we think we can get the
most new information the Nuance the
Insight that can actually help us to
Target this one dollar that we're now
trying to stretch
um
I don't think anything here is
surprising
um those that were struggling before as
key populations are struggling even more
now that we are in a post sort of
post-covet kind of World
um so I I'm not super help hopeful that
we're going to change that problem
unless we shine a light on the laws the
policies the norms and that's going to
come from very local data for local
change and Community Land monitoring can
get you to that kind of um information
um
yeah I think I'll pause there
thanks really important points because
um I love the way that we know what to
do we just don't do it
um you know I I've seen that in the
United States where as public health
officials
um people are blaming it on the client
um rather than fixing the problem
um and I think we've seen that with key
populations now for decades we're seeing
that now in the United States where
people are saying you know it's how you
voted and because you voted you're doing
worse well no that's our job as public
health officials it's not it's not to
point out the problem it's to fix the
problem and I think that translation of
pointing out the problem to fixing the
problem and being honest of whether we
fixed it or not not whether we felt good
that we tried to fix it but we actually
fixed it I I do believe that that's
where the intersection of community-led
monitoring is and I think we're still
not really there in making that happen
in a real way rather than you know it's
a nice to have what was shocking to me
is
um
as you remember there was this process
called pfips and and pepfar and
um an issue of decreasing money and
upper middle income countries
what was very interesting to me is the
very first thing to go
was the community health workers and the
community outreach groups and the
peer-led
um very first thing to go so we have an
Evidence base of what's valued when
money gets tight and I think
um the World Bank the funders pepfar
global fund the policy makers who the
Strategic Alliance and data group of
unaids they need to give voice to this
it needs to be very clear we know what
decisions countries will make
um about their health system when
financing gets tight and I think we just
have to state that and then track that
as well as what we're doing in key
populations is to say you know how many
community health workers are there how
many community-led groups are there what
is the investment in community-led
monitoring and and the funders need to
be holding countries to account because
I
it shocked me that it was the very first
thing to go
um which really I guess gets you insight
into what is valued
um Michael
yeah I think thank you um just just so
much
to this conversation and I just wanted
to add I think obviously in the last
couple of years and maybe the last
decade we've been speaking about leaving
no one behind and it's become a
reoccurring theme and actually we are
constantly leaving key populations
behind it's just because something we
just have to say because we need to say
it to Safe face and we just say oh my
God leave no keep operations behind
Michael I really appreciate your
comments the other about a couple years
ago I was on a zoom and one of the
activists said I'm just so tired
so tired of repeating the same things
and and things not happening and I think
you know having been in the position of
running a program it's very difficult to
admit to yourself that your program is
failing people because you don't want to
believe that and I think
I think we have to and I hate to put
this always on to The Advocates but
you're gonna have to be that Stark
um and say okay you made this promise 12
months ago let me just show you nothing
has happened
um no one's additional has been served
we're still missing these groups it it's
still because those are the hard
conversations that we had to have behind
closed doors with Ministers of Health
um I'm sure you know when we would all
get together there was that public
sessions but then there were very
private sections that said you know what
do you do about this because it's bad I
mean and you've got to really be that
honest that it's not working and I think
um
I know it's hard to challenge people and
say it's not working
um but that's what we need to hear
because in the end
we have to make it work for everybody
and if it's not working for everybody
that's on us the people who have the
money the people who can drive policy
with that money
um that is really on us and I think
there's a huge moral responsibility when
you are in charge of programmatic money
that you recognize that it's it's more
than what you as you described it's more
than new infections it's it's quality of
life it's how people live it's it's
using your funds in a moral and ethical
way to address barriers that exist for
40 years and shouldn't have been there
but it is your job I mean yes you could
get there going around a Securities
route perhaps but then it's not a
lasting change that really serves the
community and I think that's always hard
for program managers but you know
getting the preserving the dreams
funding and the key population
investment Fund in a very different
Administration and where that wasn't
probably part of their core values is
what we can do together when we work
together and I think there should never
be an excuse that people can say oh the
administration because it's the
program's job to figure that out because
administrations change and Investments
change and donors change but you have to
really continue to push that program and
I think I was always grateful that the
community trusted me enough to be honest
so Michael starting with you
one policy or one investment change uh
one policy will be I would really I'm
looking forward to seeing how who can
help us provide more direct link about
structural interventions and link to
incidence reductions I think we have the
the the the sort of implementation
policy for key populations document the
Miss means and it and the translator one
I think we really need a direct link
about how because we see this as a
stigma reduction it's a human rights
issue but actually there's a link to
instant introductions so I think if wh
can help us provide a guidance to
government and to us as advocates to use
as a tool to sort of towards perform
Global fund to say actually investing in
this can reduce new infections that's a
policy issue but a second layer I really
looking forward to see again reinvesting
in PL HIV is so key and it's transfer
medium in terms of U equals U because
you cannot achieve that first year if
you don't get people on treatment and
sort of getting important treatment
requires investment in the field and
invest in treatment literacy that's so
important also looking forward to the
new who guidelines on on you know our
viral suppression
great so launch
yeah I think I would I would think about
this from a donor investment side
um I really would want to see a a shift
um of donor investments from like
handouts and derivatives of aid
um to be real investment in communities
Beyond demand creation and advocacy and
a little project here and there I think
in in age 2020 there was a lot of
questions about if we had to do it all
over again how what would we do
differently and what could we engage in
and the answer was resounding and even
from this web discussion today uh engage
communities terrific Regan obviously we
need to fund the community of lead work
and the work with communities directly
but I think we need to invest in work
that actually moves the laws and the
policies in a different direction and
that's partially advocacy at the very
highest level and it's education it's
taking this data and showing people
showing leaders that if they don't do
this work that they don't want to do if
they don't you know to Michael's point
do something different with key
populations and change the way they
think about the human beings who are in
the key populations they're never going
to end their pandemics and they are you
know you've used the word moral many
times Solange it is true they there's a
responsibility that comes with
leadership and this opportunity that we
have to stop people from suffering and
from dying when we have the tools to
prevent those things and it was one
thing we didn't have them it's another
thing you know now that we have both the
ability to entirely prevent every new
infection and to keep everybody from
developing AIDS so I think it's it's
very high level work that we need to
invest in that's a combination of you
know the partners on this call and other
partners with the communities going to
leaders and and saying we need to do
this because this is you know we've
we've swirled for years this is it we
are at that point where the stuff that
nobody wants to do is the stuff that we
have to do to end it and we have to do a
better job helping people understand
that if they don't do that these things
will go on forever and will continue to
threaten everybody not just people in
key populations they're threatening key
populations Partners which is not okay
and they're threatening The World At
Large and even the people themselves are
making decisions so we have to keep
making those links that and helping them
understand that key populations do not
live of in a bubble they live in the
real world and also to I think reinforce
that moral obligation
um and I think finally the
non-negotiable nature of pandemics it's
It's they don't go away they get worse
and you can try to ignore them you can
pump them to the next you know
Administration or parliamentary group
but um really you you when you have a
moment like you have with HIV you have
to seize it you have to double down
because you will then also free up your
resources for the things that are coming
down the pike and we know they're coming
so it's incredibly irresponsible to to
dilly dally in a moment when you have
the capacity to capture uh the online
there so I think it's it's about
advocacy at the highest levels
Meg
yeah thank you I think
um From whs perspective the policy item
we'd like to see is that our key
populations in those five area of
interventions are actually adopted and
implemented and you know put into
practice at the CCMS at the cop guidance
and at all the discussions that are
happening for the next several years of
funding and all of those and I think it
would be excellent to be able to work
with Michael and others on
if those guidelines and if those
recommendations are put into place which
are pretty all-encompassing that we can
show that there's a shift in incidents
and we would love to be able to to show
that for the investment as well I think
I always look at life a little bit more
with the glass half filled and half
empty and
I sometimes I think about how we're
always talking about the zero-sum game
that we don't have enough money and I I
don't know if all of you have listened
to what Paul Farmer was speaking but it
came back again and again with his staff
this past year is that we're not asking
enough we we're saying we have a limited
um a limited ceiling on health
investment and it might be naive to say
that we can grow that ceiling of Health
investment
but we should be able to do it we've
been able to do it when we have needed
to do this for uh War for security and
health is just as much of a security
threat so could we grow can we grow and
not make this a zero-sum game where we
have to compete with a limited a limited
ceiling of finances and um it may be one
of those things I don't know how to
effectuate but perhaps people like
Ambassador and others who are working at
that high level can say let's grow let's
grow what we're going to put in so if
every Ministry of Health Ministry of
Finance could grow and commit a greater
proportion of their GDP to health and to
key populations to HIV I think that
would be something that could have huge
effects because many times we're just
waiting for the pepfar funding for the
global fund fun funding and I don't
think as we look to the long term we
should be talking that way we should be
talking about what is the ministry what
is the country doing for its population
and calling it and calling them out and
asking them to grow the pot of money for
health
so that would be my one wish
so incredible points I it's vibrant
discussion
um my really bottom line take-home
message is is where um Meg where we
started where you said
person-centered care
and it doesn't matter if that's access
to testing access to prevention access
to treatment or access to viral load
what matters is that the person has that
information and I think we can chart
where we're failing and I guess I'm
going to put out something kind of I
like to be provocative and a little bit
wild it's the way you push the envelope
but maybe we admit that our current
approach of funding through the public
sector is failing key populations and
move those resources to peer-led groups
like they did in Ukraine and I think we
do have a clear evidence base from The
Fast Track cities that those cities
succeed when they move money from the
public sector into the community funding
and peer-led and so I think the real
call to action is what is global fund
and pepfar moving
funds based on that need
to community direct Service delivery
outside of the public sector and just
admit that it can't be done there and I
think we'll see that with other
pandemics that not everything can be
done through the public sector or the
current health system and and I think
we've talked about Community Health
Systems and Community Health Systems
strengthening but I think HIV which is
always pushed the envelope
should push it now to say 40 years in I
think we can admit we started with key
populations it's still our Gap we've
tried it through the traditional Health
System strengthening and now we need to
say we're going to take a different
approach and all of that money that we
would have put towards key populations
we're moving it out of the public sector
and into the community peer-led and I
think holding
funders and policy makers to that shift
remember the government of Ukraine used
to fund those directly themselves it
wasn't just all donor money and I think
if we want to change how people look at
things we have to drive that change and
be part of driving that change so thank
you so much for your time today I have
so much respect for each of you because
you were willing to take the time to
call out mistakes and say you're not
doing this well and I think that's the
best thing you can hope for as a program
manager that people believe you're going
to listen and act so they're willing to
invest that effort so thank you for
investing that effort in me thank you or
continue doing invest that effort into
others because the one thing about the
HIV aids field I hope we can always be
honest with each other
thank you
thank you thank you